hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm five
for brown Pfeiffer brown is the lead in
the movie the gallows produced by Warner
Brothers New Line Cinema and bloom House
the film is now available on blu-ray and
DVD you should check it out and on the
on the blu-ray specifically the entire
first version that we shot like
two-and-a-half years ago with a
different cast member and it is it's on
it's on the blu-ray and I have yet to
see it do what we should do any motive I
know thank you
we should do like an entire hour and a
half of our reactions to the first so
we're gonna jazz and the dead - Dead -
Dead so we're gonna check out the
trailer for silent retreat psychological
thriller she hasn't come back and she's
thinking all day anybody seen Rita she
just talked super weird star goes by
brutal crime that's a private
psychiatric hospital in the mountains
near Tehran
I can relate it's a police report most
of the girls town had been cut out
why am I so damn I'm sure they'd be dead
by now dear life yeah just on the
process of remodeling with the whole
interiors brand new
it's been remodeled yeah
where did you get this
looking for
this isn't a vacation Zack it's a
retreat a silent retreat nina dobrev
joins a ride movement no hmm those are
some really hot actors listen I'm not
one to really bag on movies but that
looks very amateur and it doesn't look
like it's I don't get it like I saw
blood
I saw hot people I saw beautiful scenery
well the cabin they're retreating to is
a former mental asylum or something so
like crazy shits going down
why are a bunch of people in the I
thought that they were renting like the
cabin but then there's like people in
all the other rooms yeah we have another
serial killer story they start off like
cutting I saw a long creepy guy like
with his shirt has letters melt out and
like a cute little like conservative
teenager girl but then there was that
boy in the background yeah it's so
confusing then like blood everywhere
couldn't tell who is the good guy the
bad guy
why just happened the main actress
though seems so stiff the main actress
though seems so stiff
she has like no emotion and she's
reading lines yeah which you know what
as an actress I understand that
sometimes you just get really crappy
scripts and there's nothing you can do
about it so made I blame it on the
script but a lot of the quality
especially the exterior moments like
without other trees and stuff and the
fights are going on there's no intensity
there's no intensity I mean yeah it's
just a trailer so you're not really
getting the whole context of the
situation however the way it shot the
audio and it just feels very amateurish
it'd be one thing if like they were
having fun with this but they're so
obviously trying to be taken seriously
why you're like it feels too amateur to
be taken seriously like I totally agree
you know it would be better if they try
having some fun with it instead of
trying to be taking some damn seriously
they should have called us before they
film yeah yeah they should have called
us because
we know I react to other people's
content it is just as hard as putting
together one of these I have every right
to be as judgmental about the filmmaking
processes I want to be amen
well that know if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Pfeiffer brown like we said
earlier season the gallows which is now
on blu-ray and DVD check it out
now we're gonna I'm gonna be released in
a vlog soon I went through the Honda
amaze based off a gal was up in a Fresno
some fans out there we were there
together and you can also catch her on
Facebook fan page Instagram Twitter vine
she's all over the place so make sure to
follow her and oh and follow my dog on
Instagram can I do that ah I am Dean
Brown he's a pressure sort of question
to all who love people and fringe did
your cat's not have instagrams you wait
what are you uh why'd you talk like that
Tim's made us okay
hey guys I've been watching your stuff
for a while and love the reactions I
only have two favors a wine is reactive
that metal returns if you haven't seen
it please give a shout out called dem
boys prank so I am actually planning on
checking it out with Veronica when she
has the time so busy promoting a [ __ ]
film she's a star affliction what's the
film before a religious it's not my
child belongs to my friends with the
high school way that I said I try to
help out and ask for people to watch
thing that's no problem
they just started anyway thanks guys
keep doing what you're doing you guys
are awesome as tits if you didn't
already know
Wow fims Nate us you know what things
need us is right it's a certain kind of
sex maneuver you're lying
no fems need us your line just sounds
exactly like that
Finn's natus is when you pinch the man's
nipples you twist them while biting on
his earlobe and then you go into a
handstand as a woman and then he eats
you out while you flick his holes
how do you know all this
it's the things Nate us once I knew
Veronica was into it we fell in love no
fins name this I'm never gonna be able
to forget that no well just imagine
Veronica's doing a handstand and
flicking my balls